qu'un d'entre nous doit à tout prix
limiter le nombre de personnes avec qui
il est en contact chaque jour les
scientifiques le disent c'est la
priorité absolue c'est pourquoi après
avoir consulté écouter les experts le
terrain et en conscience j'ai décidé de
renforcer encore les mesures pour
réduire nos déplacements et nos contacts
au strict nécessaire dès demain midi et
pour quinze jours au moins nos
déplacements seront très fortement
réduit cela signifie que les
regroupements extérieur les réunions
familiales ou amicales ne seront plus
permises se promener retrouver ses amis
dans le parc dans la rue ne sera plus
possible
il s'agit de limiter au maximum ses
contacts au delà du foyer partout sur le
territoire français en métropole comme
outre-mer seules doivent demeurer les
trajets nécessaire nécessaire pour aller
faire ses courses avec de la discipline
et en mettant les distance d'au moins un
mètre en ne serrant pas la main en
embrassant pas les trajets nécessaire
pour se soigner
évidemment les trajets nécessaire pour
aller travailler quand le travail à
distance n'est pas possible et les
trajets nécessaires pour faire un peu
d'activité physique mais sans retrouver
là encore des amis ou des proches toutes
les entreprises doivent s'organiser pour
faciliter le travail à distance et quand
cela ne sera pas possible
elles devront adapter dès demain leur
organisation pour faire respecter ces
gestes barrière contre le virus c'est à
dire protéger leurs salariés ou quand il
s'agit d' indépendants se protéger eux
mêmes le gouvernement précisera les
modalités de ces nouvelles règles dès ce
soir
d après mon allocution
toute infraction à ces règles sera
sanctionné